today on the matt well show as we await
a verdict in the kyle rittenhouse case
we asked this question is it possible
for anyone to get a fair trial in a
modern america or has the media
effectively put an end to fair trials in
america we'll talk about that also an
fbi whistleblower reveals that merrick
garland lied when he was testifying to
lawmakers about the fbi's pursuit of
parents at school board meetings plus a
waffle house customer claims that a
waitress committed a noose-related hate
crime
when has a story like this not been a
hoax maybe this will be the one
exception probably not in our daily
cancellation we will finally once and
for all cancel sesame street it's been a
long time coming we'll get to that much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
as an increasing number of companies
fall all over themselves trying to
appeal to the left wouldn't it be nice
to find one company that actually
supports your values and where you don't
have to hold your nose while you're
supporting them
well here's one company charity mobile
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice with five
percent of your monthly plan price uh
going to the charity of your choice and
they've sent millions of dollars to
charities so far and will send millions
more in the future new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation
so that means that on top of supporting
a great company and the most important
cause the pro-life cause you're also
getting a great service
plus you can get a free christmas gift
with every phone from charity mobile
while supplies last so they're at it's
it's a win-win it's already a win-win
now it's a win-win-win charity mobile
makes it easy to switch as well if you
kee if you you could keep your existing
phone if you want
um and you could keep your existing
phone number as well if you need a new
phone though as many people do no
problem charity mobile has a variety of
options from basic flip phones and
low-cost smartphones to the latest 5g
phones and you know this is important to
me because i'm always preaching about it
you can ask them about their new flip
phone with parental controls that allow
you to disable mobile data usage text
and picture messaging and more and if
you're going to give a phone to your kid
then please i beg you to take advantage
of that
of that service as well so switch to
charity mobile now and support the
causes you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code welsh as the jury in the kyle
rittenhouse trial continues its
deliberations deliberations that should
have lasted about five minutes before
landing on a full acquittal on every
single charge it's been revealed that
the prosecutors who already committed
quote unquote grave constitutional
violations according to the judge who
said that during the trial
went back to that same bag of tricks by
withholding evidence from the defense
reportedly uh the daily the daily mail
reports quote prosecutors in the kenosha
shooter trial withheld evidence from the
defense that was quote at the center of
their case
only sharing the high definition drone
video footage on which they have hung
their prosecution
after the trial had concluded
dailymail.com can reveal assistant
district attorney thomas binger played
the enhanced drone footage to the jury
during his closing statements and
claimed that it showed rittenhouse
pointing his gun at people an assertion
that opened the door to state the state
claiming that written house provoked the
violence on the night of august 25th
2020. now in the motion obtained by
dailymail.com written house's defense
insisted
that the state only shared it with the
defense after evidence had closed on
saturday november 13th
this is just one of the grounds on which
they have made a motion for a mistrial
with prejudice filed by kyle written
house's defense monday afternoon and a
uh a mistrial with prejudice by the way
means that uh it's they can't they can't
refile it mistrial and then that's it
double jeopardy would apply so if you're
wondering why the deliberations are
taking so long this is this is part of
the reason the jurors have been
bombarded by lies from the district
attorney and every underhanded dirty
tactic has been utilized
uh for for rittenhouse to have any shot
at a fair trial he would need 12 jurors
who are first of all smart enough right
and savvy enough to wade through all of
the
half truths and untruths and falsehoods
and fabrications spotting you know the
sleight of hand tricks and the red
herring distractions along the way and
somehow sift the truth out of all of
that
but and that would be tough enough to
find 12 people who can do that
but that alone is not enough it's not
simply a matter of being intelligent and
observant something that i mean the
average person let's face it is not
that's why we would call the average
person average
but also they have to have the courage
and the wherewithal
to do the right thing at potential costs
to themselves
you know that's not the kind of
calculation that a member of a jury in
the united states should have to make
the whole system breaks down
when members of jury start balancing you
know the right verdict on one hand
against their physical safety on the
other because they can't have both when
that becomes a mutually exclusive
proposition
where you could do the right thing or
the safe thing
when you're in when you're deliberating
that's when the whole system breaks down
but that's where we are
the system is breaking down
and that's the case no matter the
ultimate conclusion of this trial
it's already taken longer than it should
precisely because of the way the game
was rigged
and who rigged it we should ask
well the prosecutors of course
we know that and also the media
i mean the media has intentionally made
it so that men like kyle rittenhouse
cannot get a fair trial in the united
states of america period
we live in the information age which is
not to say the truth age this is not an
age of truth it's an age of information
because information is not always true
we walk around every day inside this
tornado
this never-ending tornado this storm of
information most of it false and
misleading
and nobody can really escape it now what
this means is that the media has the
absolute power to pollute any jury pool
that they want to pollute
they can do this absolutely if they
decide
that they want you to be convicted of a
crime
if you for whatever reason fall
into their crosshairs
and you might be sitting there thinking
well i don't have to worry about it i'm
not
you know i'm not a prominent person
they're not going to come after me
well you never know kyle rittenhouse was
not a prominent person before all this
happened
you never know when they'll when they're
when the spotlight will fall on you in a
way you don't want it to fall
and if they decide that they can craft a
narrative about you
craft it quickly almost at lightning
speed really
and in this and at the with the same
speed
send it around the entire world and
inject that narrative straight into the
minds of the masses once it's there once
everyone has been exposed to it
and most have come to believe it because
that most people do most people just
accept whatever they're told
once that happens you cannot possibly
get a fair trial
your only hope at that point is that you
manage to extract a fair outcome from
this incredibly unfair situation and
that's possible
it's not likely
i mean it is possible
but whether you get the right outcome or
not the fact remains that you did not
have a fair trial
so when i say that fair trials are over
in america that's true they are over
they don't exist
anymore that's but that's not the same
thing as saying that um every innocent
person will be found guilty and every
guilty person will be found innocent
sometimes even in an unfair situation
just by happenstance
um
against the will of the people trying to
rig it the right thing can happen but
that's but that's going to be the
minority of cases
and so we're left with this kind of
farce
the legal system itself has become a
farce thanks to the media
we talk about an impartial jury but we
all know that every single person on
that jury
had heard about kyle rittenhouse every
single one
they're not going to find anybody
especially in kenosha who's never heard
of that
and every single one of them again every
single one without exception
had been exposed to 18 months of
propaganda painting kyle as a murderous
white supremacist
every single one of them has been has
been living in that environment
not only that but we also know that all
of them again every single one no
exception is aware of the potentially
devastating personal consequences of
passing down an acquittal
so we all know this
which means that the trial from the very
start is a charade it's a pageant
and all we can hope is that kyle manages
to free himself from its clutches like
he freed himself from the clutches of
the mob in kenosha even with the odds
stacked against him
the media has subverted
our justice system
and ripped our country to shreds
they deserve not just to be sued into
oblivion though they do of course
deserve that
but to be put in prison
i mean the media members responsible for
this should be in prison
this is the way elected republicans need
to start talking
yeah i don't want to hear vague general
complaints about the media anymore
what they need to start saying is that
this is criminal
and we're going to put you in jail for
it
the people who lied about the jacob
blake case in the first place in order
to provoke the riots
provoked them by the way as part of a
larger effort to influence the
presidential election
and then lied about written house they
shouldn't just face monetary
repercussions they should be in jail
they should be locked in cages like the
rats they are
they have no right to do what they're
doing this is not free speech
this is this is a terrorism is what it
is
of course the left has never met a truth
that it won't deny so they'll still
claim that uh really when it comes to
the justices in fact they'll agree that
the justice system is rigged and that
it's unfair and everything and that it's
all a farce but they would say it's
because of white privilege and uh and
white people are so privileged and they
have the advantage and they still claim
that somehow
um you know that that somehow kyle
rittenhouse is getting better treatment
than he would if he were black and they
say this even though
we all just witnessed only a few weeks
ago a black school shooter waltzed out
of jail less than a day after opening
fire in his classroom
and then go home to a welcome home party
that was broadcast live on facebook
not only that but we also saw gang
members in chicago shoot each other in
the street
in full view of security cameras by the
way
leading to at least one person's death
and none of them were charged with
crimes
to reiterate straightforward homicide on
camera
and there were no charges
none
not even for um illegal firearm
possession or you know
i don't know disturbing the peace not
even so much as a misdemeanor charge for
first degree murder
privilege i mean what what white
privilege the court system
no that's not the kind of privilege
you'll find in the court system and it's
not black privilege either necessarily
if kyle rittenhouse were black but but
still but but you know associated with
being right-wing
and um and i don't even know if that's
true i don't know what his politics are
but that's how he's associated so he
were black and associated with being
right-wing and he had been in kenosha
under the same circumstances and
everything had played out the exact same
way
he'd probably still be facing the same
fate
in fact just as the media is calling
rittenhouse a white supremacist right
now even though he shot three white
people who were attacking him i have no
doubt that they would still call him a
white supremacist for shooting white
people even if
even if he was black provided that he
was associated with being right-wing
so the privilege in the court system
just as in society at large
is uh is is not strictly racial it's
ideological it's determined by the media
most of all the media dispenses the
privilege right the media decides who
will get favored treatment and who will
not
the media's rigged the entire system
destroyed the entire system
so so trump was right
it was the most right thing he ever said
the most correct he ever was
was when he said the media are the enemy
of the people
because they truly are
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
a couple weeks ago we introduced to you
this incredible new app and i get people
asking me about it all the time is it
really as good as it sounds is is it
really that there's you know there
what's the catch well there is no catch
get upside app is what it's called and
uh it's all upside there's no downside
to it and when you get the get upside
app you are getting cash back every time
you buy gas and we could all use a
little cash back now especially with how
expensive gas is my listeners are making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
the free get upside app in the app store
or google play right now use promo code
wall should get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents cash back
uh and you don't have to pay full price
of the tank anymore there's no reason to
do it you can get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cashback on your first
tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two or 300 a month in cash
back
and there's no catch again the cash back
is added right to your account you can
cash out anytime you want paypal e-gift
card for amazon
and other brands you can use as well or
just go right to your bank account and
you get that money in your pocket as
quickly and easily as that so download
the free get upside app and use promo
code walsh you get up to 50 cents a
gallon cash back on your first tank
that's code walsh so the daily wire is
on the scene in kenosha um
outside of the the courthouse and
they've had there's been a few
interesting interactions so we'll start
with this i want to play this for you
here's the daily wires georgia howe
talking to uh this is jacob blake's
uncle who is who's there
and um now let's let's just remember
again we have to review this all all
over again because this this all started
with with jacob blake
who and really it began not even at the
police shooting it actually began
when he allegedly uh broke into a
woman's home
uh early one morning on sunday morning
and uh and raped her and then stole her
credit card and her vehicle and drove
away now the thing about that
is um he was never convicted in that
case in fact they dropped they dropped
the charges for that
this happened a few months ago and of
course there was no there was no outrage
from the metoo set or anything i mean
this was a guy accused of of breaking
into a woman's house and raping her and
they dropped the charges
and and yet what we know and part of the
reason by the way they said they dropped
the charges is that they weren't getting
a lot of cooperation from the victim
but of course you're not going to get a
lot of cooperation from the victim
because the entire media and society and
culture and everything they're all on
jacob blake's side they they have made
him a hero he's a folk hero
and so that's what she's up against
and so she's afraid for her own
well-being
not without reason
and i would imagine that's why she was
not very cooperative and they decided to
just take that as an excuse to drop the
case entirely but we still know
you know this was not one of those cases
where jacob blake was accused of rape uh
10 years later or or 30 years later you
know like a brett kavanaugh situation no
the morning of this alleged incident
the victim called the cops
trembling and crying and telling them
what happened you know
in her pajamas
and they showed up and the morning that
it happened
so i guess you could decide i mean did
she just wake up one morning and decide
to you know this was she was going to go
go for an oscar and and
put on this whole show
it seems pretty clear to me that that
you know
that we could drop the alleged from the
rapist part but i'll keep it on there
just for litigation reasons
um so that's that's where this begins
and uh it has to be in there because
he's got a warrant from for his arrest
stemming from that
and then he shows up again to his
alleged victim's house
and uh he is accosting her and she calls
the police to come and save her from
this violent scumbag of a man the police
show up he fights the police
uh pulls a knife on the cops
and they're still doing everything they
can to apprehend this guy without
without he gave them an excuse almost
right away to just shoot him there on
the spot and shoot him dead
they gave him a reason as soon as he
pulls the knife out that's their reason
but they still didn't
and he walks around the car not his car
it's his victim's car where there's
children inside and the cops are trying
to stop him and telling him to stop
telling him to stop and he starts to
climb into the car where there are
children into a car that is not his
while he's wielding a knife and so we've
got this knife-wielding accused rapist
trying to steal a car with children
inside and that's when they opened fire
and they were absolutely justified in
doing so um
so that's what happened with jacob like
and that's and that's where all of this
begins
in fact if we were to start if we were
to make a list of who to blame for the
written house shootings
who's really to blame for it well first
we have the the rioters who attacked
uh ridden house and then we have the
media
for ginning up this mob and this riot in
the first place again in an effort to
influence the election
and then we have the government
officials who abandon their communities
to the mob and but then also jacob blake
he's he's actually the first to blame
he's the one who started all this
and yet in spite of all this jacob
blake's family they're still out there i
mean they got a visit from the president
and the vice president
you know president president and vice
president made their state visit
to the here the folk hero jacob blake
accused rapist knife-wielding madman who
tried to kidnap kids and steal a car uh
they made their visits and um and the
family is still you know they're they
have no shame whatsoever they're still
out there
painting them even they're a victim too
by extension
so that's the context and here is uh
georgia howe we'll watch a little bit of
this talking to jacob blake's uncle
now a lot of people have been making
this about race and i noticed we have
some black lives matter protesters here
um do you think this case is about race
of course
i'm going to be just cold blooded honest
with you of course it is a young black
man was shot seven times in the back who
was never charged with any crime who was
not being aggressive and who had his
back turned on a police officer
and now that's a lot but when it comes
to the kyle rittenhouse
all of the men that he shot were white
so how is the kyle rittenhouse case
about race so to be blunt with you back
in the 50s 40s and 60s they would refer
to them as lovers so they were
sacrificed they were sacrificing this
young man was used
so if they can uh what with the tone
that we're setting today is that i don't
believe our uh uh caucasian counterparts
are willing to give up the lives of
their young people on the street this is
no different than the shooting in
colorado the shooting in florida it was
a young person because he would have
been in high school or just out of high
school and he shouldn't have had a gun
and he murdered people with the gun that
he had illegally some people would say
you know jacob blake was visited in the
hospital by the vice president of the
united states they would say that is a
form of privilege sort of like what
you're discussing let me tell you i wish
you would mention the president of my
presence
he has failed us he has betrayed the
floyd family he's betrayed the uh taylor
family after taylor
i love that they still haven't looked
okay
we can cut out of this we've heard that
we've heard this guy babbling enough
just lying i mean it's just someone with
no soul whatsoever he knows the truth
this was a this was a nonviolent jacob
blake was a was a good young man
he didn't do anything right he was
charged he wasn't charged with any crime
they were there to warrant out for his
arrest he wasn't charged with any crimes
many of those charges have been dropped
for political reasons
but but
a fair number of the crimes he committed
is
are on camera we can all see him do it
and they continue right along with the
narrative it doesn't matter
uh but he still they still don't he goes
on for a while there it's actually an
interesting conversation i was going to
continue playing it but i just i can't
stomach listening to this guy anymore
um
i really don't want to hear from anybody
in the in the blake family
but he it's it's great that he doesn't
like joe biden you know joe biden showed
up
joe biden showed up and like bowed
before this absolute scumbag jacob blake
this nothing of a worse than a nothing
this absolute total dirtbag jacob blake
nothing positive can be said about this
man he's contributed nothing positive to
society only negative he has been an
absolute net negative for humanity in
every single way jacob blake
um
he gets shot by the police
totally deserves it every every bullet
he took he deserves
and uh the president still shows up and
bows before him at his hospital bed
and what are the the blm protesters say
still not good enough
not enough
it's not just not enough we we hate you
they don't even know why they hate them
like what else what more do they want
joe biden do they don't know
but their whole gig is to be perpetually
aggrieved
no matter what so if you're in a
position of authority they're going to
hate you because you're
they are all they are the victims
and if you're running the system then
you are responsible for victimizing them
no matter what you do
meanwhile we had some other uh
protesters who were on the scene
and protesters on both sides of it let's
let's watch a little bit of
some some of the pro some of the
anti-written house protesters uh and see
maybe a few of them will make some
interesting points maybe they can
explain why they're there and they could
be eloquent and articulate about it
my hopes are not very high but we'll see
i wanted them to think of the word hero
when they see anthony huber
i want them to think hiro because you
guys
they were running after kyle not to like
kill him
they were just trying to stop him
because he just shot somebody they're
treating him like a child and making it
as comfortable
and as
non-threatening as possible
and what did you make of the footage of
the actual incident did it look like
self-defense or not self-defense to
you it looked like
a crazy situation
it looked like it looked like murder to
me
and uh
it was an illegal
horrendous act
has it been your opinion that kyle has
been treated as you as if he was
innocent
i don't have an opinion on that
uh it's really up to the jury to decide
what's going to happen you don't have an
opinion on that so uh what are you doing
there with a with a poster board sign
you idiot here to call kenosha to come
together to denounce the hateful
ideology of white supremacy as depicted
he's shouting into a lampshade by the
way
and pudgies clever and in mount pleasant
wisconsin there's a here's a man uh
shouting kyle is a killer community into
his into a lampshade
all right
so there you go
i love the one guy he's got a sign
calling for a conviction of call right
now i really have no opinion
about about the case i think the jury
should decide what are you doing
protesting though if you if you want the
jury to decide
well they they have no idea these people
have no clue whatsoever
useful patsies
for the left that they're out there but
it is interesting
you know
uh that
it's not a huge crowd
outside the
courthouse there's a great amount of
interest in the case obviously and if
you go online you see i mean every
leftist is calling for cal written
house's head but it's not a big crowd
out there
it's it's really a very sad assortment
it reminds me of the people who
protested at netflix because of dave
chappelle it might actually be the same
people
or or you know maybe they all kind of
end up looking the same slightly
overweight oftentimes not the stereotype
but
uh
this sad pathetic assortment
like a handful of people out there and
that's why i might end up eating these
words but
um
you know most most people on the right
most conservatives are kind of
predicting and expecting that if that if
a written house is acquitted
uh that there's going to be massive
massive riots and it's going to be even
worse than it was in 2020 after the
jacob blake shooting and there's
certainly a possibility of that but i
wouldn't put my money on it if i were to
far to put money down on something like
this uh i would not put my money on
massive rides there will be some
protests
but it's probably not going to be
anything like it was in 2020 and why is
that well because as we said what why
did the me the media there was a reason
why the media made the decision
to foment these riots at that point it's
not a coincidence that this happened to
be
uh right leading up to a presidential
election that's why they did it
you know they were trying to get people
fired up in a very literal sense
with this idea that it's a it's it's a
racist system and that we you know this
it and it it also gives it gives
everyone the impression when there's
rioting and there's violence in the
street and everything it makes people
more inclined to want change and so they
got to get rid of whoever's on the top
uh they don't want this now because
democrats are running the system so they
don't they don't want that
you know this feeling of unease and
chaos and violence they don't want that
even though there is a lot of chaos and
violence in in the streets of our cities
whether there's riots or not but the
other problem is
they realize that democrats are running
the system right now
so a riot because everybody is upset
about systemic oppression and and
systemic racism and everything
well that's going to put the blame on
the democrats who are running the system
right now
therefore the media has no real interest
in fomenting riots uh the riots in 2020
across the country these were not
organic things these these we're not
spur of the moment spontaneous
doesn't go there's a reason why we saw
you know van showing up with signs and
all the rioters were carrying the same
signs the same kind of slogans
these were funded these were coordinated
these were promoted they had the whole
pr mechanism of the media behind it
that's not going to be the case this
time so i would expect no matter what
happens the trial it's not going to be
the same kind of reaction
um though i could be
incredibly wrong about that all
right let's
and then and then obviously had a lot of
protesters also saying that uh that kyle
rittenhouse
shouldn't have been there so this is
across state lines even though he he
lives 30 minutes away and he worked
there and his dad lived there but he
crossed state lines and he shouldn't
have been there you hear this a lot this
is something here on the right also
david french wrote an article recently
saying kyle ryden house is no hero he
shouldn't have been there
and quickly to address that notion one
more time
if you are saying
that kyle rittenhouse shouldn't have
been there
and really that's irrelevant to the case
whether or not it was self-defense
whether he should have been there or not
it's irrelevant but
if that's what you're saying that's the
position you're taking then what you're
saying
is that
when the government surrenders
your community to the mob
and surrenders it to anarchy and
violence
and says that they will not uphold the
law anymore for a period of time
what what what the he shouldn't have
been there folks are saying is that your
moral obligation
is to sit there and take it
and i guess hunker down batten down the
hatches go into a storm cellar and wait
for it all to be over and hope that your
house isn't burned down in the process
that's what you're saying
now that that is the actual reaction of
most people
but is that like the morally right
reaction
when the government decides there's
going to be this huge hole this void
where they're not going to enforce the
law are we is our is it our moral
responsibility to say well the
government doesn't want to enforce these
laws anymore so well that's it
or are we morally justified in stepping
into that void and saying if you're not
going to do it then we have to do it
i would say that you are morally
justified okay
huge development here report from yahoo
it says citing an internal email
provided by an fbi whistleblower
republicans on the house judiciary
committee revealed tuesday that the
bureau has created a system to track
threats against school board officials
and administrators
and accused attorney general merrick
garland of misleading lawmakers when he
asked about the subject during his
previous testimony when he was asked
about the suspect during his previous
testimony before the committee the fbi's
counterterrorism and criminal divisions
created a threat tag
edgio officials
to track instances of related threats
according to the email the purpose of
the threat tag is to help scope this
threat on a national level and provide
an opportunity for comprehensive
analysis of the threat picture for
effective engagement with law
enforcement
the email was signed by
counter-terrorism division assistant
director timothy langdon and former
criminal division assistant director
calvin shivers who retired earlier this
month
in the letter to attorney general
merrick garland representative jim
jordan the ranking member of the house
judiciary committee wrote that the house
the whistleblower email provides
specific evidence that federal and law
enforcement uh
officials employed counter-terrorism
tools against concerned parents
the fbi has denied this if you if you
care at all what the fbi has to say
here's what the fbi says in the wall to
the wall street journal statement the
fbi has never been in the business of
investigating parents who spoke out or
policing speech at school board meetings
and we are not going to start now the
creation of a threat tag in no way
changes the long-standing requirements
for opening an investigation nor does it
represent a shift in how the fbi
prioritizes threats
well of course merrick garland so he
lied he perjured himself
he should be disbarred from that for
that he should be he should be he should
resign in disgrace uh but neither of
those things will happen
and the problem is
there's there's no denial from the fbi
that that matters to anyone at this
point i mean nobody has any faith in the
fbi
um
how is this going to work when we get
into you know federal criminal trials
and that sort of thing
it's all based on work by the fbi and
fbi testimony
you've got people from the fbi up there
on the stand testifying
nobody trusts them no one believes
anything they have to say
and that's something they brought on
themselves and when you weaponize the
fbi against average americans well
average ordinary americans like parents
that's going to change how they see the
fbi
so this is the great crisis that we're
facing it's a total collapse in trust in
our institutions
and you can't you can't have a
functioning society
when no one has any faith in in in the
institutions underpinning it
one of one of our most fundamental
institutions is
uh the court system the justice system
law enforcement
and when no one has any faith in any of
this stuff
then it it as i said it breaks down
although maybe i keep using the phrase
breaks down i probably shouldn't because
that makes it sound sort of accidental
it's not being broken down it's more
being demolished deconstructed as the
left likes to say
all right i want to get to this
this is from the gainesville times so as
a gainesville woman says she was
threatened at a waffle house on november
7th by employees who said they needed
nooses after her biracial family walked
in to eat
um while at the waffle house in
gainesville
a woman angelica tabor fells
recorded a video describing the
allegations which has since gone viral
and tick-tock with 2.5 million views
um of course and so there's you know
this has already gone viral the the
police department is investigating it
the waffle waffle house has released a
statement it's a whole thing
let's watch we have the tick tock video
here is what's her name again angelica
tabor fells
with a story of a noose related hate
crime these things are always okay up
until this moment and we'll watch it
together and we'll see what we think
about it but up until this moment
these stories have always been false
i mean like 100 of the time for the last
30 years at least any time there's a
claim of a noose-related hate crime or a
racist incident involving a noose it is
always false every time it's incredible
that we have
i mean to bat a thousand on something
like this is pretty incredible uh but
maybe this will be different maybe this
is the one real one
the one real incident
let's watch and find out
so we're at waffle house in gainesville
i'm 129.
look at my family it's very diverse
didn't i see my family
so i'm about to show you a waitress that
decided to ask for a noose
in front of me and my daughter
[Music]
and then when i asked to speak to the
manager the manager who said that he has
two nooses in his car
so i'm pretty dag on shore this is
probably the racist place i've ever been
[Music]
now they're trying to hide
ma'am can i get my um ticket to go
because miss thing over there needs a
noose and we're the only black people in
here
and your manager said he got two nooses
in his car so we're getting the hell up
out of here
and i need a number for corporate
okay
uh i mean i don't mean to laugh at your
pain um
miss angela angelico angelo whatever
your name is
uh i i just angelico's name
yeah
i i i find this extremely hard to
believe i really do
so
some customers walk in
and the waitress looks at them and says
i gotta grab my nooses
and the manager says i gotta fuel my car
go grab
what
it doesn't even make any sense what like
okay did she say oh i i need to get some
juice do i mean can we go through words
that rhyme with noose here
so of course as we said batting a
thousand these stories are always fake
uh and i gotta say this one
this this one i would put on the tier of
uh the claim a couple of years ago that
there were new racist nooses hanging
from a um
at a cracker barrel that someone had put
there and then it turns out that they
were just cords like extension cords so
i would say i'm going to give this a um
99.9999999
chance of being false
let's just let's let's
round up and call it 100
these stories are always fake and i'm
and i'm thinking this one's going to be
no exception
uh you know
there are if we wanted to to break this
down and analyze it there are a number
of questions we could ask probably no
reason to do it but here's one question
why would they be the first black people
at this waffle house to have this
experience
i mean if this waffle house is that
racist that you simply walk in and they
start talking about going to grab a news
wouldn't there be other customers who
would have similar stories
or are we supposed to believe that these
are the first black customers that have
ever gone into this waffle house are we
really supposed to believe that
waffle house in gainesville is never has
never seen a black customer before
that's a you know i'm not i'm a big fan
of waffle house by the way
assuming that they're not committing
hate crimes like this if they are then i
will not go on any more waffle houses
but
uh on the assumption that they're not
i'm a big fan of waffle houses myself um
and i consider myself to be sort of
aficionado of waffle houses and what i
will tell you is one of the great things
about it is waffle houses are very very
diverse um i i've never been to a waffle
house that was anything less than
racially diverse i just that that's
another thing that makes this story not
make a lot of sense okay um what else do
we got here
uh
yeah i i tried a few days ago to talk
about this britney spears thing um
britney spears
this is the story from elle magazine i'm
a big reader of elle magazine
is a couple days old now but a los
angeles judge ruled that the
conservatorship that has control britney
spears's life for over 13 years should
end today according to new york times um
the pop icon now 39 years old has been
under the court ordered legal
arrangement since 2008 following
struggles with her mental health and now
uh the conservatorship has ended
yeah i've been threatening to talk about
this and i you know they're more
important things to talk about
so i've kind of skimmed over it
um
i i have the same
i have followed this this story as i
said not very closely so maybe i've
missed something along the way
but
um as happy as i am for britney spears
that she's uh free now and she can do
whatever she wants that's that's
wonderful because i had i had something
i've deeply been i personally had been
deeply worried about for the last 13
years i have not been able to sleep well
at night knowing that britney spears is
under a conservatorship so i feel i feel
that relief like everyone else does
but the reason she was under the
conservatorship is because she was
judged mentally unwell and so mentally
unwell that she was a danger to herself
and others that's also why she lost
custody of her children which is a very
hard thing to do as a woman it's very
hard to lose custody of your children
especially in i believe this was in
california so to be in california and to
lose custody of your kids
that that is not that's not something
they do lightly
anywhere but especially in california so
that was the judgment
um
that she was a psychologically unwell to
the extent of being a danger to herself
and others that's why she was under the
conservatorship
um
i assumed that the people who wanted the
conservatorship to end
i assume those people aren't claiming
that it's impossible for someone to be
judged mentally unwell and unable to
care for them you know to a threat to
themselves and others obviously there
are people who fall into that category
and so there should be arrangements like
conservatorships for those sorts of
people
we should also have institutions to put
them in and we used to you know we don't
we don't do that nearly as much as we
used to but
assuming we can agree on that the
question is is that the case for british
spears
and i guess my point is i don't really
know but all the people calling to the
conservatorship to end do they have
evidence do they have some information
about her psychological health could
they somehow prove
that she was not as crazy as they said
i never saw anyone produce that evidence
it's just sort of an assumption
this is what the court had decided and
there's an assumption that it's false it
could be wrong we just talked about not
trusting the court system but do you
have any reason to think that
and
if the original judgment was correct
that she's a danger to herself and
others
and now she's been released of this
conservatorship and then she goes on to
hurt herself or hurt someone else you
know
all the
protesters who've been calling for this
for the last several years
how are they gonna feel then uh one
other thing we gotta we gotta mention
this also um
some closure here from the new york post
brass against rocker sofia urista has
apologized for going too far by peeing
on a fan on stage uh while insisting
that she's not a shock artist okay it's
not this is not something she normally
does
in fact she's never peed on someone's
face on stage before
if anything is something she does in the
privacy of her own home and uh she
always makes sure to take sanitary
precautions puts down some newspaper and
all that sort of thing so not something
she normally does she got carried away
this is her statement she says i've
always pushed the limits in music and on
stage that night i pushed the limits too
far
i love my family the band and the fans
more than anything and i know that some
were hurt or offended by what i said
and so that's a sh she apologized
we all make mistakes sometimes you
accidentally pee on someone's face on
stage it happens
i would like to get an explanation be
interested in what the explanation is
like what was the thought process that
led to this
i'm curious
um
but we don't need to talk about it
anymore this is this whole thing is
gross it's just really not my cup of p
to be honest um
sorry i used up all the good urination
puns yesterday so i'm i'm all out the
bladder is empty you might say
i just wish this video had never leaked
i mean talk about a live stream
okay i'm sorry i'm done you know this
singer she's not a big star in the music
industry she's like a little star really
so she went tinkle tickle little star
okay that was that was a bad one i i
even wrote that one down can you believe
i wrote down tick i wrote down tinkle
tink a little star so i could tell that
joke and i and i hate myself for it now
i really do let's go to the comment
section
[Music]
uh you're killing me smalls says hey ben
shapiro hey ben shapiro referred to you
as my friend matt walsh during the q a
with the trans activist who couldn't
answer what is a woman that was
heartwarming
i did see that exchange ben shapiro
speaking uh in in florida university of
florida i believe
and uh he he had an interaction with the
trans activist and he dropped the what
his woman question and gave me some
credit for that
and of course the response from the
trans activist was there was no response
as always i think the transaction the
trans activist accused ben of a red
herring fallacy
and this is something you know people
who grow up on the internet at a certain
age they're very impressed with
themselves because they know about
certain fallacies and so their response
to any argument you present is always to
um
label it with a certain fallacy and then
to define it for you well that was a red
herring fallacy that was a red herring
fallacy and a straw man fallacy and a
um
it's not a red herring fouls is the
opposite of red herring this is this is
the whole point you know
can you within the context of gender
theory even define what these genders
are if you can't and that shows that the
whole thing's incoherent and the the
other the other interesting thing is
that ironically while accusing
ben of a fallacy the trans activist is a
p
their entire argument
is
um structured around an appeal to
authority
listing all of these supposed public
health authorities who have said that
actually you know it's great to give
kids hormones and everything so that's
the whole argument as an appeal to
authority while accusing ben of a being
a trans activist as far as calling me
his friend i do appreciate that because
if i was in his position and the roles
were reversed
i would refer to him as my subordinate
and employee i certainly would so i
appreciate that on his part
um
jimmy says matt giving away the banjo in
order to get out of playing it for his
adoring fans such a chad move yeah i
feel like that needed more explanation
than we gave it that was sort of out of
nowhere it wasn't we are giving away the
banjo
and uh
if you if you
this is something this is a gift we're
going to give to a someone who signed up
for our newsletter
the the matt welsh newsletter and so if
you want to win the banjo you have to
sign up for the newsletter but i do want
to clarify one other thing
obviously i'm a legendary banjo player
and that's why you would want the banjo
and this is a banjo that's near and dear
to my heart because i've played many
many tunes and many melodies on it many
beautiful tunes um i'm always walking
around the office any anyone at daily
wire will tell you i'm always walking
around the office
playing music singing
bringing joy to everybody that's just
what i'm all about and they call me the
music man actually that's that's the
nickname they give me but
the banjo that's in my studio right now
that the alien is holding that's not the
original banjo
okay that's my daily wire nashville
banjo which we will be giving away but
don't worry there will still be a banjo
on set the original banjo from my studio
in my house
that will replace it so everything will
be fine you'll get a banjo i'll still
have a banjo and everything will be
great but you got to go to
dailywire.combanjo
to sign up and possibly win it
um
cyril says
oh i saw a fairy in the garden what am i
the only person who never believed that
fairies and unicorns were real matt
makes it seem like it's normal for kids
to do this as a child i always had a
very good idea of what was real and what
wasn't and i think it was because my
parents said the exact thing matt is
mocking before you say that i'm a
special case i have three siblings who
shared in this upbringing and has
similar early understanding of these
things so either all four of us are
special cases or there may be something
to that approach uh no i
i was not there for your childhood
far be it for me to say but i will tell
you be far be it for me to tell you what
happened in your childhood but i will
tell you what happened in your childhood
and i can tell you 100 certainty
you definitely at some point in your
childhood believed that things like
fairies and unicorns and dragons and
everything were real you absolutely did
and the reason that you did is because
you were not born with the brain you
have right now which is a really good
thing because if you were you would have
killed your mother on the way out okay
so you were your bor your brain was not
fully developed as it is right now
hopefully as it is right now
and um early on in childhood once again
you do not have the uh the neurological
equipment in place
to differentiate between real and not
real okay so when you go to a
two-year-old and you say such-and-such
is not real it's a fantasy
that doesn't mean anything to them they
don't understand the difference okay
which is why little kids they there's
they're afraid that there's a monster on
the under the bed you could explain to
them no monsters aren't real that
doesn't even make any sense what would a
monster be doing under your bed in the
first place i mean if there were
monsters it wouldn't be under your bed
in any way uh here i'll turn the light
on you can look under there's nothing
there and that's not enough to convince
them
because they see it in their head they
feel it
and so it's real to them
and the idea that you could feel
something see it think it and if that
it's not real
that's something that's a realization
that develops later in life if you're a
leftist it never develops right
so that's the case for everybody um
and you're no exception you might not
remember those times because it was a
long time ago
let's see uh bh says if you have to wear
a band on your wrist to relieve you from
your helpless feeling of nausea you are
a female
how dare you sir
how dare you
more bigotry against the motion sick
community the msc as we call ourselves
we are not actually we are not motion
sick people by the way we are people of
motion sickness inclination
and how dare you once again i say you're
banned
uh
nate says conservatives there's no such
thing as your truth your personal
experiences don't determine reality
walsh if you don't have kids your
opinions on anything parent related is
completely irrelevant and silly
okay well this isn't about people having
their own truth okay
i'm not saying that if you're a parent
you have one truth and if you're not a
parent you have another what i'm saying
is that if you aren't a parent
you can't really know the truth about
parenting there are certain truths
certain realities of parenting that you
can't really know until you are one
and this is something that i i know if
you're not a parent and you know if
you're younger
you don't believe me on this you don't
think i'm right i was in your shoes too
okay there was a time in my life when i
was younger and i was childless and i
sat there judging parents and making all
of these declarations sometimes in my
head sometimes out loud about what i
would do as a parent and how everything
would be as a parent and what it you
know
and i was it before i had is what i can
tell you before i had kids i was an
absolutely perfect parent
perfect i was a model for everybody else
and then i had kids and i start to
understand certain realities that i
simply didn't have access to when i
wasn't a parent and when you have kids
this same thing will happen with you i
guarantee it
you will look back at the things that
you said and things you thought before
you had kids and you'll and you think
what a [ __ ] was i
um so that's just
i could tell you take it from me i know
you won't but it is the truth uh
regardless now a word from lifelock
you've probably heard of phishing
attacks phishing emails well what about
spear phishing attacks that's the latest
thing these targeted attacks focus on an
individual and try to trick them into
revealing personal information by posing
as a trusted friend a boss a company
family member uh so the the bad guys out
there online are getting
uh you know as as we why
get wise to their tricks well then they
pull another trick out of the bag and
that's the way it goes and that's why
you need to protect yourself with
lifelock it's important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day because
they are i mean every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
your reputation they can really destroy
your life in a lot of ways uh and that's
why it's so good there's lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
threats of identity threats like your
social security number being for sale on
the dark web if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised they'll send you an alert so
look nobody can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25 off your first year by
going to lifelock.com that's
lifelock.com walsh for 25 off we just
talked about it but i'm going to
reiterate again if you have not signed
up for my newsletter yet then uh frankly
i've uh that offends me and it hurts my
feelings and it should be enough that i
simply demand that you do it but if i
have to coax you if i have to bribe you
than i will uh because right now
starting right now if you sign up for
the newsletter and you're on the email
list you will have a chance to win
my very special banjo not the mo it's
like the second second most special
banjo that i own uh the one that right
now the alien in the back of the the
studio has been taken care of for for so
many months but now you can own it
yourself own the legendary banjo that
has been played and enjoyed by legendary
banjo player matt walsh go to
dailywire.com banjo to subscribe my
newsletter and uh get your chance at the
banjo today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
all right so today we cancel sesame
street we could have canceled sesame
street a week ago when big bird tweeted
big bird has a twitter account now by
the way he tweeted that he'd just gotten
the vaccine despite having natural
immunity
from respiratory viruses due to the fact
that puppets don't have respiratory
systems but i suppose if we're giving
the vaccine to kids who are almost
completely immune to severe coba illness
then we might as well give it to
fictional birds also to make matters
creepier big bird then appeared on a cnn
town hall to further push
pharmaceuticals onto kids
big bird seems to have really settled
into his new role as drug dealer um
here's what that looked like
you know my granny bird says that since
i'm six years old i can get the vaccine
oh yeah that's right big bird
but well i have a lot of questions like
what is a vaccine and does it have to be
a shot and and will i still need to wear
my mask those are such great questions
big bird and it turns out lots of kids
and families have questions too so over
the next half hour we're gonna be
answering your questions talking with
experts and giving you the information
you need about vaccinations for kids
oh um
uh you know what
elmo better guard change see you later
[Music]
oh come on it's time for the town hall
[Music]
okay this raises um
a number of questions questions like
what the hell happened to big bird's
voice
why does he sound like a child molester
now he's he sounds distinctly creepy all
of a sudden also what kind of
six-year-old is watching a cnn special
about vaccinations in the first place
who is this
who is the audience for this
when i was a kid the only thing i knew
about cnn was that it's the channel my
dad watches sometimes when he wants to
yell at the tv which come to think of it
explains a lot in any case this is all
very weird and inappropriate and
dystopian and horrible as a show for
preschoolers hawks a drug that nobody in
the preschool demographic actually needs
but that's not why i'm canceling sesame
street
it would have been it would it would
have been the reason until they gave us
a whole new reason
as abc reports quote sesame street
debuts ji young the first asian american
muppet that's the headline the article
says at only seven years old g-young is
making history as the first
asian-american muppet in the sesame
street canon she's korean-american and
has two passions rocking out on her
electric guitar and skateboarding the
children's tv program which first aired
52 years ago this month gave the ap a
first look at its adorable new occupant
g young will formally be introduced in
see us coming together a sesame street
special simolu padma lakshmi and uh
naomi asaka are among the celebrities
appearing in the special which we'll
drop on thanksgiving now if you want to
see xi young in action which i know you
do
here she is
actually there's something really cool
about my name uh so in korean uh
traditionally the two syllables they
each mean something different and she
means like a
smart or wise and um young means like uh
brave or courageous or strong yeah and i
think it was honestly inspired
unfortunately by um but the past year
and the rise in um you know attacks and
and uh racist incidents against asian
people especially during covet my one
hope
obviously is to help have chiang help
teach you know
what racism is help teach kids to
be able to recognize it and then speak
out against it but then my other hope
for jiung is that she just normalizes
seeing different kinds of looking kids
on tv and i'm excited to share kim pop
and toki and kogi and jiggy's and
and all sorts of stuff
oh yes okay well we need the asian
muppet to tell kids about racism in case
they didn't pick up on the racism
lessons from literally every other show
or movie they've ever watched it's very
important to see that we don't allow
young children to go more than 17
minutes without being reminded of racism
even 17 minutes is probably too long i'm
concerned that you know
like spaghettios hasn't released a new
product product where the letters in the
soup are r-a-c-i-s-m
so that even when they're eating they
can still be reminded of racism
plus as the as the puppeteer behind the
asian muppet explains we also need to
normalize asian people for kids
this is important in case there are any
children in america who've never seen an
asian person before we need to think
about you know all those kids maybe who
were raised
inside a crater on the moon and haven't
encountered any members of another race
or ethnicity
we need to make sure we normalize other
ethnicities for all of those moon
children who might be watching but this
all leads to a confusing question
g young is the first asian puppet on
sesame street
okay
well then what race are the other
muppets
what race is ernie
what is elmo's nationality
where is grover's ancestral home
we know that the count is from
transylvania so we know that uh we know
oscar the grouch is from new jersey
which is why he prefers living in a
trash can but the rest of the characters
seem to be very intentionally non-racial
i mean what the hell is snuffleupagus
supposed to be
does cookie monster have an ethnic
background
i guess he's from new jersey also in
fact he was the governor of the state
from 2010 to 2018 but you see the point
most of these characters have no
ethnicity
no race no nationality they're fictional
fictional characters that all children
can relate to equally and i think that
was sort of the point right
they exist in a fantasy world where
there are no races
and there was a time when this this was
the liberal utopia a world of sameness
where nobody is different everyone is
the same and when it comes to things
like gender that kind of homogenous
ambiguous paradise is still what they
strive for but the realm of race
in the realm of race as equity replaces
equality the pendulum has swung back in
the other direction dramatically and now
rather than than emphasizing
similarities and downplaying differences
the left wants to make sure that
everyone is categorized and labeled and
put into a box
and it makes things even more confusing
because we
our gender is all fluid and there's no
differences and it doesn't matter but in
a ra but as far as race goes we are
strictly in our box and we can never
leave it
they want kids to see themselves in
those terms
sesame street actually has been pushing
this message for a little while now they
debut they debut their first black
muppets a few months ago
and uh here's how those characters
explained race
well it's because the more melanin you
have the darker your skin looks
the color of our skin is an important
part of who we are but we should all
know that it's okay that we all look
different in so very many ways
elma's fur is red and soft oh and my
hair is black and curly
things on the outside like our skin
color our hair texture
our noses
our mouths and eyes
make us who we are
many people call this
race our skin color is what makes us who
we are
says the black muppet
as woke sesame street tries its hardest
to ensure that kids see race first and
foremost
uh but our skin colors what makes that
when i was a kid watching sesame street
the message was precisely the opposite
of that
of course the funny thing is you'll
notice um the asian puppet
doesn't actually look or sound all that
asian
and so this is always the conundrum for
the identity box checkers when it comes
to cartoons and puppets they want to
make sure that there's proper
representation but they also can't allow
themselves to be accused of stereotyping
which is a problem because when you're
making a puppet or a cartoon that's
supposed to represent a certain race
then inevitably by definition there is a
caricature a stereotype
going on
but they can't do that yet they want to
have the representation which just means
that the diverse characters
meant to represent a specific ethnicity
or race end up representing really
nothing and nobody in particular they
want to racial racialize the fictional
world as much as they've racialized the
real world but they can't really do that
because then they'd be engaging in
stereotypes so they're left then with
this weird kind of half measure
which is what wokeness always boils down
to it boils down to incoherence and
weirdness in the end though on a
different note
i'm wondering if we'll see the episode
where the asian puppet ji young
applies for college and is turned down
in favor of the black muppet you know
that that would be you know that's
another important real world lesson
about equity maybe we'll get that as
well um and i look forward to that but
in the meantime
sesame street we must say is canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
vadowsky the show is edited by ali
hinkle our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair makeup is done by cherokee
heart and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
blm threatens riots in kenosha the white
house hangs kamala out to dry and ted
cruz destroys joe biden's secretary of
homeland security check it out on the
michael knowles show